المترجم: Aya AlAjjan
المدقّق: Sarah Shahid
من منكم يعرف أغلى بيتزا في التاريخ؟
أغلى بيتزا في التاريخ..
آه موضوع آخر،
ما جئت أتحدث عنه اليوم
هو شيء يتعلق بالنقود.
منذ زمن بعيد، أو أن الصغار منكم
يسمعون قصص أجدادهم
بأنه وُجد قديم. اسمه بيتكوين، اسمه قرش.
هذا القرش الذي نتعامل به اليوم،
سنتخيل أنه أكبر قليلًا.
فلنتخيله أكبر بكثير،
فلنتخيله أنه بارتفاع هذه القاعة،
ولنتخيل أنه أكثر سمكًا، بهذا الحجم،
هكذا سنحصل على حجر، ليس خيالًا،
اسمه حجر راي، أو حجر النقود،
وهذا الحجر موجود في جزيرة اسمها YAP،
وهي في المحيط الهادي.
محمد، أحد سكان هذه الجزيرة،
يرغب في شراء بيتزا من عبد الله،
ذهب إليه وطلب منه أكبر بيتزا موجودة لديه؛
قال له: "ممتاز، سعرها حجر واحد"
كما ترون حجمه هنا.
بالطبع لن يحمل محمد الحجرة ويأخذها إليه
لا، بل كان هناك حل أذكى من ذلك؛
ببساطة، قرروا أن يصنعوا
سجلاتٍ في هذه الجزيرة
ليدونوا فيها الأحجار، وبجانبها
أسماء أصحابها.
عندما قرر محمد شراء هذه البيتزا،
ببساطة تغيّرت السجلات.
أحبّ أحدهم أن يصبح غنياً أكثر.
أحضر سيولةً جديدة، طلبها من البحّار
وأحضرها البحّار إليه.
وأثناء عودته غرقت السفينة
وضاع المال الجديد "الحجر" في المحيط.
فذهب إليهم وأخبرهم بأن
الحجر أصبح في المحيط؛
قالوا: "لا مشكلة، برغم ضياعه في
المحيط، سندخله في السجلات"
وأخذوا يتعاملون به رغم عدم
رؤيته في الحقيقة.
هذا الحديث قديمُ الزمان، لكن يوجد
حتى الآن.
كيف ذلك؟
ببساطة، لأنكم تقبضون أموالكم اليوم
من البنك من الشركة التي تعملون عندها،
لأنها ببساطة قررت أن تغير السجلات
وتضع أسماءكم على جزء من أموالها.
هذا حديث اليوم، إنما في
المستقبل القريب جداً
سنستخدم عملاتٍ من نوع جديد؛
سنستخدم BitCoin.
قرر محمد من جديد الذهاب إلى
الخباز عبد الله
لكنه هذه المرة متطور وسيشتريها
عن طريق الإنترنت.
ماذا سيحصل؟ ذهب إليه
وطلب البيتزا؛
قال: "لا مشكلة، ثمنها 10 آلاف
من BitCoin،
قم بتحويلهم لي".
ماذا سيفعل محمد؟ أولاً يفتح
حساباً في شركة BitCoin،
لماذا؟ لأنه كما نحن بحاجة لحساب
فيسبوك كي نتواصل مع مستخدميه؛
فأنت بحاجة لحساب شخصي على BitCoin
كي تحوّل النقود لمستخدميه.
حسناً، وماذا بعد؟
سجل حسابه، ذهب إلى عبد الله،
وبعثهم إليه برسالة عبر الشبكة
بمنتهى البساطة..
حسناً، بعد تحويلها قد نفكر،
لماذا سأستخدم هذه العملة؟
ماذا أستفيد منها اليوم؟
في الحقيقة، عملية الشراء هذه ليست خيالاً
وحدثت في الواقع في 2009،
و10 آلاف BitCoin كانت
تعادل حينها 25 دولاراً.
اليوم، تعادل ذات الكمية 10 مليون دولار!
لو كنت أملك هذا المبلغ لن أشتري به البيتزا
ولكن، كيف يمكنني الاستفادة منها؟
هل تغني؟ ترسم؟ تصمم؟ تبرمج؟
أو حتى تكتب الشعر؟
من الممكن أن تضع هذا المحتوى على
الإنترنت وتجني مقابله عملات BitCoin.
عندما نتحدث عن BitCoin
فنحن نتحدث عن الأسعار
كونها "عملة"،
ثمن هذه العملة -بالرغم أننا
نتحدث عن 10 آلاف منها-
لكنها تُقسم كثيراً، وأصغر قسم منها
"القرش" الذي يتبعها
أو لنقل قرشين، أطلق عليهما اليوم
اسم "ساتوشي"؛
2 ساتوشي = قرش ونصف.
تخيلوا الدقة!
أي في المرات القادمة لن تذهب
إلى التاجر فيعطيك علكةً بباقي الثمن.
حسناً، قبضت من BitCoin، ماذا أفعل بهم؟
ببساطة، يمكنك شراء أي شيء.
نحن بدأنا بالبيتزا أجل، لكن سننتهي
بشراء السيارات، البيوت
وأي شيء تريده.
حسناً، بحديثنا عن BitCoin نحن
نتحدث عن الإنترنت،
وحين نتحدث عن الإنترنت،
نتحدث عن الأمان
ما نسبة أمان هذه العملة؟
ببساطة، لم يستطع أحدٌ اختراقها حتى الآن.
لماذا؟ لا ليس من قلة المحاولة؛
حيث أن الناس حتى الآن يحاولون اختراقها،
لكن تشفير هذه العملة أقوى من أقوى
حاسوب بـ 250 مرة!
وليس ذلك فقط، كي تدخل إلى حسابك
الذي تمثله حقيبتك --
هذه الحقيبة،
كي تدخل إليه، أنت بحاجة لتطبيق
ثلاثة أمور كي تؤمن حسابك:
الأولى: كلمة المرور، ببساطة.
تدخل إلى الحساب وتكتبها، وماذا بعد؟
يصلك بريد إلكتروني يؤكد لك بأنك
أنت من قمت بالدخول
فتدخل إلى البريد وتؤكد هويتك، وبعدها؟
تصلك رسالة قصيرة على الجوال تحوي
رمزاً معيناً للتأكيد على أنك أنت
من قمت بتسجيل الدخول وبأنك تريد تحويل
النقود بكامل إرادتك
حسناً ..
فلتفكر بـ BitCoin، والإنترنت،
وبالنقود التي في جيبك.
لم لا نجعلهم واحداً؟
فلتفكر بشركة مثل أمازون،
وصلت أرباحها هذه السنة إلى ما يزيد
على 104 مليار دولار!
فلتفكر بـ iTunes، التي تسيطر اليوم على
أكبر قسم ممكن من الميديا في العالم..
اسأل نفسك، ما الذي يمنع أن ننشئ نحن شركة
قد تصل مع الأيام إلى حجمٍ كهذا؟
اسأل نفسك، ما الذي يقف بين الإبداع،
وجني المال منه؟
لم لا نجني المال من الرسم؟ من التصميم؟
من أي شيء؟
مثل ما يتم الدفع له في الأسواق العالمية؟
يمكننا في الحقيقة، والسبب في إمكانية ذلك
هو BitCoin.
شكراً.